rumeur de dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale ou de remaniement ministériel
les contacts se multiplient entre le
gouvernement et sa majorité
la mecque le dernier bilan de l'incendié
qui a ravagé un camp de pèlerins
musulmans et de 250 morts et plus de
2000 blessés
onze ans après la catastrophe de
tchernobyl un village des vosges
s'inquiète de la radioactivité toujours
présente dans son environnement sport
cyclisme victoire de l'an jalabert donc
fait cheval
madame monsieur bonsoir l'incendié qui
s'est déclaré hier soir dans un
campement de pèlerins musulmans autour
des lieux saints de la mecque en arabie
saoudite a fait au dernier bilan de 150
morts
plus de 2000 blessés c'est une bonbonne
de gaz servant à faire la cuisine qui a
explosé entraînant une autre série
d'explosions en chaîne et un incendie
que les secours ont eu beaucoup de mal à
maîtriser étant donné la concentration
de pèlerins dans cette zone
environ deux millions pendant la semaine
de pèlerinage
thierry thuillier ils n'ont pas renoncé
à leur pèlerinage même si en chemin tous
sont en tête
le drame d'hier l'ascension du mont
arafat pour tout musulman c'est le
moment fort du voyage à la mecque alors
ils sont plus de 2 millions à être venue
comme chaque année imploré le pardon de
dieu sur cette colline où adam et eve se
serait retrouvé après avoir été chassés
du paradis à une dizaine de kilomètres
de là dans la vallée de la mine à houlle
incendie a fait près de 250 morts et
deux blessés bilan encore provisoire
de nouvelles tentes ont commencé à
remplacer les 70 partis en fumée hier le
gouverneur de la région afin que l'
incendie n'est pas criminel mais bien
accidentel consécutif à l'explosion
d'une bonbonne de gaz
le feu s'est rapidement propagé les
tentures peuplaient sont ici côte à côte
la configuration des lieux a compliqué
le travail
sukkur saoudien ils n'ont pu parer au
plus pressé
beaucoup des victimes la plupart
indienne et pakistanaise ont été brûlées
très gravement et les autorités
s'attendent à une aggravation du bilan
dans les prochains jours la mecque et le
premier lieu saint de l'islam où chaque
musulman pratiquant se doit de se rendre
au moins une fois dans sa vie chaque
année donc à pareille époque deux
millions de pèlerins environ se
rassemblent ce qui pose aux autorités
saoudiennes d'importants problèmes de
sécurité comme en témoigne ce document
philippe rochot en sandales et portant
l'iram ce vêtement blanc sans boutons en
signe de pureté
ils sont plus de 2 millions à venir ici
chaque année accomplir le cinquième
pilier de l'islam
un casse tête pour les autorités
saoudiennes qui ont dû établir des
quotas de pèlerins par pays
il a fallu créer un ministère du
pélérinage avec des employés
spécialement chargé de suivre les
pèlerins on a peur des clandestins et
des terroristes
la grande mosquée de la mecque est
placée sous haute surveillance 24 heures
sur 24
laravine oublie pas la prise d'otage de
79 qui a fait 150 morts et les
manifestations des islamistes iraniens
ou 400 pèlerins ont été tués
les organisateurs du pèlerinage doivent
aussi compter avec ces malades qui
veulent toucher la pierre noire sacré
avant de mourir il faut aussi surveiller
l'aération des tunnels qui relient les
différents lieux saints une panne du
système de ventilation avait provoqué
l'asphyxié de 1400 pelles rail
l'un des temps forts du pèlerinage c'est
la lapidation symbolique de sa tante
c'est pour ce rite que les centaines de
milliers de pèlerins dorment tamina dans
ces tentes qu'ils nous aux organisateurs
du pèlerinage
c'est là que l'incendié a éclaté les
pompiers de la mecque formés
spécialement en occident tout comme les
policiers qui surveillent le pélérinage
n'ont pu intervenir à temps à cause de
la foule qui chaque année des bords de
la ville sainte pendant le mois sacré
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour la
monarchie saoudienne
car elle sait que pendant la semaine du
pélérinage le monde musulman a les yeux
tournés vers la mecque
ces documents dans sa totalité sera
prochainement diffusée dans l'émission
la 25e heure sur fond ce un incendie
criminel cette fois ci la nuit dernière
c'était au portugal à amarante dans le
nord une discothèque à brûler faisant 12
morts 14 blessés c'est un commando de
trois hommes cagoulés qui est entré dans
la discothèque ils ont arrosé les lieux
d'essence avant d'y mettre le feu les
portes des issues de secours étaient
bloquées on pense un règlement de
comptes entre propriétaires de boîtes de
nuit en france les députés discutent
actuellement du projet de loi contre
l'exclusion sociale l'opposition
reproche au gouvernement la faiblesse
des moyens financiers engagés
le premier ministre lui parle d'une loi
d'encadrement qui ne doit pas se
substituer aux initiatives privées ou
local premiers exemples la poste pour
tous ceux qui sont privés de compte en
banque
les mandats postaux sont un moyen de
paiement qui reste très utilisé 14
millions par an et très prochainement
ses mandats postaux pourront être
honorées dans n'importe quel bureau de
poste
reportage philippe visseyrias jean-paul
chausset il vient ici une fois par mois
pour payer son loyer et pour retirer ces
allocations chômage jacques giguère à 58
ans sans travail depuis quatre ans
pas exactement le genre de personnage
dont raffolent les bancs je me sépare
fond et pour vous envoyer par h
parce que on peut répondre franchement
enfants interdits quai plus droit
aujourd'hui mais je me débrouille avec
le minimum et je paye en liquide comme
jacques puis de 2 millions de personnes
en france sont interdites de shakespeare
les chômeurs pour la plupart un chiffre
en constante augmentation
la poste reste pour elle le seul endroit
où elles peuvent verser et recevoir de
l'argent ailleurs ils sont rejetés chez
nous pas ils peuvent continuer à payer
vous cet important possède encore des
services publics
heureusement jusqu'à présent le
destinataire ne pouvait retirer son
argent que dans le bureau de poste où
son mandat avait été envoyé pour
simplifier la procédure
la poste test-achats un nouveau système
informatique bientôt généralisée dans
toute la france il permettra aux usagers
d'aller chercher leur mandat dans
n'importe laquelle des 17000 agences du
pays sans rendez-vous simplifiée mais
toujours aussi cher un mandat 30 francs
environ à l'expéditeur
une grosse somme pour des genres souvent
sans difficultés
second exemple concret en alsace une
fille législations particulières
permettent aux familles surendettées de
se déclarer en faillite personnelle et
une association aide les imprudents qui
se retrouvent dans ce hit dans une
situation de non paiement de crédit à
gérer au mieux ce moment très difficile
jérôme soûlard sylvain gauthier alors
comment ça nous a offert le coffre à
jouets la literie le tout la chambre à
coucher complète nous est remis à 35
mille francs alors que vous le trouvez à
7000 francs dans un simple magasin et il
ya beaucoup de gens qui se font arnaquer
comme ça et puis suivront trop
rapidement un réfrigérateur un fou une
telle est en tout 150 mille francs de
crédits facilement accordées pour 4700
francs de salaire mensuel
les gens qui ce qui qui viennent vous
proposer ces choses là ne veut rien à
[ __ ] s'ils ne le ne récupère pas leur
argent par les traitent ils le
récupéreront parle par voie de justice
c'est ce qui s'est passé chez nous un
irresponsable ou crédules les familles
alsaciennes jouissent pourtant
quelquefois d'une dernière chance
la faillite civile une loi inscrite dans
ses vieux libres de droit datant de 1870
l'occupation allemande et qui permet
encore aujourd'hui au tribunal de
strasbourg d'annuler l'ensemble des
dettes d'une famille alsacienne comme on
le fait déjà ailleurs pour un artisan ou
un commerçant faillite aujourd'hui avec
l'augmentation de la pauvreté dans des
parties importantes de la population
on constate que c'est la seule solution
alors parfois on s'étonne que le droit
local subsiste sur certains points on
peut aussi s'étonner al'inverse que le
régime de faillite civile qui répond si
bien cette situation là n'est pas été
étendue au contraire à l'ensemble du
territoire
la faillite civile une loi d'origine
allemande qui a déjà sauvé d'un naufrage
promis des dizaines de familles
alsaciennes
cette année l'association crésus alsace
qui vient en aide aux familles a
instruit plus de 800 dossiers pour
l'instant seule une dizaine de cas les
plus extrêmes ont été déclarées en
faillite civile
bah oui je pense qu'il faut une sorte de
formule de rédemption afin que les gens
puissent de nouveau se mettre debout
avec tout ce qu'ils ont appris dans leur
expérience vraiment douloureuse cent
mille foyers français surendettés
recensés en 96 et l'année 90 est
paraît-il qui s'annonce encore bien pire
la faillite personnelle une loi pour
l'instant uniquement alsacienne et
mosellane dont voudrait bien profiter
demain des milliers d'autres familles
françaises
à nice le commissaire du gouvernement a
demandé au tribunal administratif
d'annuler l'arrêté anti mendicité que le
maire de la ville monsieur jacques
peyrat avait pris l'année dernière
la décision sera rendue dans deux
semaines le maire a décidé de se
conformer au jugement qui sera prononcé
il y à 11 ans un des réacteurs de la
centrale nucléaire soviétique de
tchernobyl en ukraine explosait lâchant
au dessus de l'europe un nuage
radioactif la france n'était pas
épargnée et 11 ans plus tard tout un
village des vosges saint jean d'ormont
vit dans la peur d'une présence de
radioactivité en relation avec cette
explosion des contrôles vont être
effectués reportage jacques cardoze josé
boulesteix un sanglier à propulsion
nucléaire dans la région la blague n'a
duré qu'un temps
car depuis ce 30 novembre jour de chasse
mémorable où l'on a découvert après
expertise un gibier contaminer la
population du village a voulu en savoir
plus et les habitants de saint jean
d'ormont ont enfin obtenu ce qu'ils
réclamaient aujourd'hui ces visites
médicales pour tout le monde si au
projet de décaler légèrement pour
pourquoi les pianos op mont-athos
reviendra encore un par un les 200
habitants subiront tous le même contrôle
il s'agit de connaître le taux de
radioactivité dans le corps on peut dire
si les gens ont de la radio était ma
radioactivité dans leur corps s'ils ont
été contaminés
ça vous êtes capable de le dire dans
l'espace
mais les habitants du village ont
rapidement été rassuré rien d'anormal
selon les experts il ya des mesures qui
sont faites de façon continue sur toute
la france par les services de l'eau prix
c'est toutes ces mesures n'ont jamais
rien montré d'extraordinaire
bon il est possible que dans une petite
région il ya une accumulation plus
particulièrement aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas connaissance
peut-être la suspecter avec ce sanglier
mais nous n'avons pas connaissance
les explications jugées insuffisantes
pour ces patients d'un jour alors même
leur alimentation doit être contrôlée
alors vous apporter du sang gré du
chevreuil et des champignons
on nous a apporté de la terre la terre
d'un jardin du miel de l'eau de source
tous deux sont ceux captés à 400 mètres
d'une habitation et plus de la terre
toutes les analyses effectuées
aujourd'hui ont révélé un taux négatif
de radioactivité mais ici personne
n'arrive à comprendre pourquoi ce fameux
sanglier avait lui été contrôlé positif
un sondage bva pour paris match et
france2 intentions de vote des français
en cas d'élections législatives
38 % de voix pour l'udf et le rpr 28%
pour le parti socialiste auquel il faut
ajouter les écologistes et le pc au
total 47 % la gauche l'emporterait donc
le front national engrangerait lui 13,5
pour cent des voix la projection en
sièges donne les résultats suivants 270
députés pour l'udf et le rpr 257 pour le
parti socialiste qui allié aux
écologistes et aux parties communes y
seraient majoritaires avec 284 sièges à
l'assemblée nationale ce sondage comme
d'autres alimente les rumeurs
d'élections législatives anticipées
démenti mais de manière ambiguë
alors que les rencontres entre alain
juppé et les membres de sa majorité se
multiplient véronique simple yves
bernard puis sow
ah non je ne peux pas commencer puisque
alain juppé ne tord pas le cou à la
rumeur d'une dissolution ou d'un
remaniement il alimente et à l'assemblée
nationale on ne parle que de ça on y
croit ou on n'y croit pas on l'espère on
le redoute mais la majorité est saisie
de tourny y compris le président de la
commission des lois le supportant ce
matin par jacques chirac à titre
purement institutionnels je ne suis pas
favorable mais je reconnais que le
président de la république est
totalement libre je crois qu'il est bon
de rendre la parole au peuple
ils conduite il ya aujourd'hui des
sondages contradictoires et bien le
mieux c'est d'aller devant les électeurs
et de laisser le juge une bonne chose et
de respecter les calendriers sauf s'il
ya des raisons valables et le sol le
prétend la république et juge de ces
raisons et il ne m'a pas fait de
confidences
alors à défaut de confidences on pèse le
pour et le contre et à gauche on teste
déjà ce qui pourrait être un slogan de
campagne s'il y avait une des solutions
serait évidemment une dissolution
recommence personnel donc
manipulation en fin d'après-midi à l'udf
on devait parler programme
mais le départ de françois léotard pour
une visite impromptue à matignon relance
toutes les supputations ya une réflexion
du président de la république et
premiers ministres
laissez les conduire cette réflexion à
long terme
pendant ce temps l elysée les
communiqués se suivent et se ressemblent
ces rumeurs dit on sont sans fondement
maison ajoute le président dispose d'un
certain délai de réflexion alors
comprenne qui pourra
alors essayons de comprendre à la chavez
qu'il se passe vraiment quelque chose
oui car même si l'elysée leur knicks
atelier venait de rappeler répond que
dissolution en maniement ne sont pas
d'actualité et bien c'est vrai le
mot-clé ses réflexions une réflexion est
engagée dont l'origine est la volonté
d'accélérer le temps politique et deux
ans après son élection
donner un second souffle au septennat de
jacques chirac alors on connaît les
arguments en faveur d'une dissolution
d'abord le souci de déconnecter le
calendrier européen du calendrier
législatif français car on est dans la
phase finale de l'entrée dans l'euro la
monnaie unique est un dérapage
budgétaire plus important que prévu nous
éloignant des fameux 3% critères imposés
obligerait un tour de vis supplémentaire
or dans un climat social qui est
toujours difficile
ensuite il ya la volonté de relancer les
réformes un gouvernement à la veille des
législatives on sait généralement
immobilisé et puis enfin la météo je
dirais est bonne car si le moral des
français n'est peut-être pas encore
confiant en tout cas les mois déprimée
aujourd'hui et le parti socialiste lui
ne décolle pas et une accélération du
calendrier éviterait peut-être que les
juges saisis des affaires comme on l'a
vu dans le passé puisse être eux aussi
inspiré par les échéances
alors il ya évidemment de forts
arguments contre la dissolution
le président de la république devra
évidemment la justifier aura plusieurs
reprises il a répété qu'il respecterait
les échéances électorales jacques chirac
ne devra pas donner l'impression d'une
dissolution de commodités à des français
qui sous la vème république sont
habitués à des dissolutions justifiée
par des crises sociales ou par
l'élection d'un nouveau président enfin
jacques chirac s'il décide de dissoudre
se mettra ainsi en première ligne au cab
la victoire ne sera pas au rendez vous
alors l'autre rumeur l'autre hypothèse
n'est pas là des solutions mais le rhum
l'iman ministériel le remaniement je
dirais que c'est une solution classique
à quelques mois des législatives on est
tous les grands ténors des partis de la
majorité dans la même équipe
gouvernementale pour aller ensemble à la
bataille c'est vrai c'est un moyen de
relancer la machine politique et si la
volonté est de créer un vrai choc
et bien la dissolution est l'hypothèse
la plus probable toutefois toutefois la
décision finale n'est pas arrêté et
évidemment elle appartient au seul
président de la république
merci arlette le premier ministre a
entre les mains le rapport officiel de
la commission de contrôle des écoutes
téléphoniques en france dans ce dossier
il faut distinguer les écoutes officiel
le sel qui sont réalisait le plus
souvent dans le cadre de la concurrence
ou de l'espionnage industriel économique
ces écoutes dites sauvages sont estimées
à environ 100 milles pour la seule année
dernière il faut imaginer que ces
pratiques peuvent provoquer la faillite
pour un entrepreneur reportage pascal
nous c'est bon michel jeannot latos
traumatisés alain hudon a été mis sur
écoute il ya sept ans ce sont des
grésillements sur sa ligne qui lui ont
mis la puce à l'oreille
il a alors demandé un contrôle et voici
ce qu'il a trouvé
lorsque le technicien des télécoms a
découvert la bretelle on a pu constater
qu'elle menait aux coffrets et df et en
ouvrant le coffret car la porte était
ouverte
on a découvert à l'intérieur un
magnétophone de marx à nyon chapeau et
1990 alain reid a créé une entreprise de
fabrication de paillettes pour
l'insémination artificielle des bouffes
mais très vite les problèmes surviennent
plus sa ligne de téléphone grésille plus
ses sous traitants le lâche
il perd alors beaucoup d'argent et doit
se rendre à l'évidence il gêne quelqu'un
un concurrent c'est ce qu'il fait qui il
voit le devance systématiquement et
l'empêchent d'entrer sur le marché
il a essayé en fait de protéger
l'hégémonie qu'il avait sur le marché
alain pêcheurs de débutants
comment vous vivez le téléphone
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui j'ai toujours la psychose du
téléphone d'ailleurs régulièrement
france télécom viennent procéder à des
vérifications à sur médine téléphonique
c'est malheureux à dire c'est à butare
j'y passe le jour le pire c'est de
savoir que quelques heures habermas ou
violent et ça c'est très très dur à
supporter le vrai coupable n'a même pas
été poursuivi l'auteur de l' écoute
condamné a refusé de donner le nom de
son commanditaire et de toute façon
celui ci ne risquait pas grand chose la
france contrairement aux états unis ne
s'est doté d'aucune loi spécifique sur
l'espionnage commercial après genève
l'an dernier c'est à bruxelles
aujourd'hui devant les instances
européennes que le groupe de sept juges
d'instruction chargés en europe des
dossiers les plus sensibles dans leurs
pays respectifs sont venus réclamer une
nouvelle fois un véritable espace
judiciaire européen leur permettant de
démêler les dossiers politico financiers
très compliqué qui leur sont soumis par
mieux le juge français renaud van
ruymbeke reportage michele finn
dominique mère ils sont les plus grands
juge anti corruption en europe en
octobre dernier il lancé à genève un
appel pour dénoncer leur impuissance à
lutter contre le crime organisé moins de
six mois plus tard devant la commission
du parlement européen de bruxelles
ils font le même constat l'argent de la
drogue a ouvert la voie il ya vingt ans
la puissance de la mafia italienne
aurait dû nous alerter
aujourd'hui l'argent collecté par les
organisations criminelles qui se
développe à une vitesse fulgurante dans
les pays de l'est et recyclés dans nos
économies occidentales sans que nous
ayons les moyens de le détecter ces
juges demandent la construction d'un
espace judiciaire européen c'est à dire
le droit de pouvoir tout simplement
communiquer entre eux d'échanger leurs
informations sans passer par la voie
diplomatique sans perdre du temps ce
genre d'espacé existe déjà de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique pourquoi ce qui
n'existerait pas de ce côté de
l'atlantique
et ça n'a pas tellement une question de
savoir si c'est une utopie ou pas c'est
une nécessité dans moins de trois mois
les pays européens vont se retrouver à
amsterdam
les magistrats aimerait que les
gouvernements profitent de ce rendez
vous on réviser le traité de maastricht
et créer peut-être un espace pénal comme
un saint-etienne de jouarres en isère
était une petite commune tranquille
jusqu'au jour où là les découvert que
l'hôtel qui servait de maison de
retraite n'avaient pas l'agrément des
pouvoirs publics bref c'était
clandestins mais contrairement à ce qui
se passe parfois et bien les
pensionnaires étaient très heureux mais
dans l'illégalité didier guyot thierry
monnier auberge duclos mignot il ya
quelques mois cela s'appelait l'hôtel
club de là car un hôtel qui en fait
était devenu une maison de retraite des
personnes âgées y étaient accueillies
nourris soignés nul d'ailleurs ne s'est
plaint si ce n'est les autorités
sanitaires car cette maison de retraite
n'avaient aucun agrément et pourquoi la
justice s'intéresse aujourd'hui à la
gérante de ce lieu ces contenants qui
répond aux normes hôtelières
le confort est incontestable et il est
assez paradoxal que l'on puisse
reprocher d'avoir propulsé le reprocher
d'avoir accueilli des personnes avec un
certain confort
c'est l'administration tout entière qui
semble là à voir quelques scrupules
hôtel de 32 lits l'établissement
recevaient essentiellement des personnes
âgées dépendantes ou nous des infirmiers
venait dé soigner du personnel les
assistait le séjour était moins cher qu
en maison de retraite mais cela se
faisait en totale illégalité
qu'importe si les clients étaient
heureux des gens en fin de vie qui se
trouvent dans des chambres coquettes
très propre avec un cuisinier qui vient
le matin demandé que voulez vous manger
à midi c'était c'était un bonheur
permanent
donc je pense que c'est écoeurant et que
je ne comprends pas que la dass n'est
pas donnée d'agrément parce que ces
petites structures il en faudrait
effectivement beaucoup la dass c'est le
conseil général de l'isère n'ont pas
voulu prendre de risques que les
conditions n'étaient pas remplies pour
être une maison de retraite officielle
alors il a fallu cerner l'actualité
internationale avec peut-être le
déblocage politique cause haïr avec la
visite du chef rebelle laurent désiré
kabila en afrique du sud où elle été
reçue par le président nelson mandela
avant peut-être d'iran
contre et là bas le maréchal mobutu
pendant ce temps à kinshasa
l'avant-dernier premier ministre a pris
la fuite pour la suisse le président
mobutu l'accusent d'avoir avant son
départ pillé les caisses de l'état
olivier lerner lubumbashi qui a retrouvé
son nom d'origine katanga tombée aux
mains des rebelles il ya huit jours à
peine n'a pas réservé un accueil
triomphal au bras droit du chef rebelle
laurent désiré kabila applaudissements
mesurés mais qu'attend gay ont déjà
perdu leur gouverneur limogé sur le
champ les méthodes autoritaire et
expéditive des rebelles ne font pas
recette ici où les habitants sont très
attachés à leur liberté
laurent désiré kabila rejette les appels
au cessez le feu mais ne dit pas non aux
négociations
celui qu'on appelle déjà monsieur le
président a pris la direction du cap
aujourd'hui invité par nelson mandela
qui va tenter d'organiser une rencontre
au sommet mobutu kabila pendant ce temps
à kinshasa certains ont pris les devants
l'ancien premier ministre kengo wa dondo
a quitté le zaïre pour la suisse après
avoir dit ont vidé les caisses de l'état
il y a trois mois nous avions rencontré
un homme serein qui se moquent reçu
comme un chef d'état en afrique du sud
ce soir
kabila est plus que jamais en position
de force
le premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou pourrait être mise en examen
pour une affaire de corruption politique
le mettant en cause ainsi que plusieurs
de ses collaborateurs
la police a fait cette demande auprès du
procureur qui doit maintenant décider ce
pourrait être l'ouverture d'une grave
crise politique en israël en albanie les
troupes européennes ont commencé à
organiser la distribution de l'aide
humanitaire encore modeste mais dont le
rythme d'arrivée doit s'accélérer dans
les jours qui viennent notamment dans le
port de doux rêves fous sont arrivés ce
matin les premiers cargos transportant
de l'aide humanitaire pour les albanais
retour en france avec les problèmes de
sécheresse qui commence à se poser le
45e anniversaire de la construction du
barrage de tignes en savoie prend donc
un relief tout particulier en effet
autour du barrage des régions agricoles
bénéficient d'abord en eau gratuite et
abondante qui permettent une irrigation
régulière des zones d'agriculture de
montagne au portage du gda 6 1 claude
bernier 235 millions de mètres cubes
d'eau une richesse solidement gardés par
le géant de tignes le barrage forme un
réservoir utiles à la production
d'électricité est maintenant nécessaire
à l'agriculture
ici comme partout en france la
sécheresse sévit avantages de cette
région de montagne la fonte des neiges
alimente les cours d'eau résultat plus
de 20 kilomètres de tuyaux parcourent la
vallée pour arroser les champs je crois
propres banderoles
enfin de digne le village qui ne voulait
pas mourir est désormais toute proche et
avant l'inexorable montée des eaux
les hommes ont commencé leur travail de
destruction une maison digne ont été
écrasés sous le poids des bulldozers
une ancienne habitante du village de
tignes qui à l'époque avait fait la une
de certains magazines se souvient de sa
difficile
expropriations critiquées
ce petit village a été le premier en
noyer de noyés parce qu'il est en
contrebas
on a retiré le plus possible ce qu'on a
peu après les bulldozer sont arrivées
jean démoli les maisons
voilà 45 ans plus tard le barrage
alimente deux grosses centrales
hydroélectriques
les retombées économiques 50 millions de
francs de taxe professionnelle versée
chaque année aux communes et aux
départements et 20 millions de francs
pour la maintenance de l'ensemble
l'électricité et l'eau deux éléments qui
ont transformé un paysage et une
économie en sport le français laurent
jalabert a remporté pour la deuxième
fois de sa carrière la classique
cycliste belge de la flèche wallonne
devançant sur la ligne d'arrivée son
compatriote patriotes que luc leblanc
très belle victoire de laurent jaladeau
l'événement cinématographique de la
semaine c'est la sortie du film michael
collins interprété par liam neeson
michael konyves fut le héros très
controversé de l'indépendance irlandaise
dans les années 1915 1920 ce film a
provoqué une polémique en angleterre au
moment de sa sortie car il fut admiré du
type de l'armée anglaise polémique
également en irlande où certains
affirment qu'il fut assassiné par un
autre indépendantistes irlandais enron
de valera qui allait devenir le premier
chef d'état de l'irlande indépendant
pascal deschamps christophe airaud
attentats sanglants indépendantistes
contre soldats de la couronne
ces images ont rarement quitté les
journaux télévisés ce film vous fera
revivre une page capital de cette
histoire irlandaise une page écrite par
un homme michael collins celui qui à 24
ans était déjà l'ennemi public pour les
anglais
c'est lui qui dès 1916 a inventé le
terrorisme à l'irlandaise organisant une
véritable armée secrète qui lui permit
de rendre coup pour coup
normal donc que le film ait provoqué
outre manche une polémique fiction
romance et il retrace faut pas
fidèlement l'essentiel d'un destin hors
du commun pour moi michael collins n'a
jamais été un terroriste un combattant
pour la liberté oui un révolutionnaire
oui un terroriste non ce n'est pas parce
qu'il était à la tête d'une armée sans
uniforme qu'il doit être jugé
quand on parle de violence les gens
toujours un point de vue partial nos
amis de la police royale irlandaise
aimerait bien le faire taire
oui me remettre en prison me tue et qui
sait
mais j'aimerais que vous leur envoyez un
message si jamais il me fontaine qui
prendra ma place
après quatre ans de lutte sans merci
michael collins accula les anglais à la
trêve en 1921 il accepte alors de signer
le traité qui coupent l'irlande en deux
seul le sud obtient un début
d'indépendance on le désaveu dans son
propre camp je t'assure que personne
n'aurait pu faire mieux larry holmes et
mais ça c'est l'abandon du nord la
division du pays
tune espère tout de même pas que nous
allons accepter de prêter serment
d'allégeance à la cour qu'ils ne peuvent
pas nous accorder la république ça
dépasse l'entendement
l'accord qu'il a négocié à fixer l'état
dans lequel l'irlande se trouve
aujourd'hui
il avait 30 ans cela fait plus de 75 ans
personne n'a été capable de retenir
davantage malgré des décennies de
violence
considéré comme un traître assassiné en
michael collins cristallise encore
aujourd'hui les haines les aspirations
et les rancoeurs de tous les acteurs la
dernière et de la plus longue guerre
civile du continent européen
le printemps de bourges comme son nom
l'indiqué clôt chaque année à cette
époque c'est devenu un classique où l'on
peut entendre tous les genres de musique
avec des artistes en devenir et d'autres
confirmés reportage louis carzou hervé
poteau lorsque les cadeaux de bouche
prennent les couleurs de l'amazone is
pas de mystère c'est l'effet pour sa 21e
édition le festival s'est ouvert sous
des termes paulette kg avec comme
toujours le cocktail à succès du
printemps deux tiers de jeunes pousses
il est chaudement suis amoureux encore
une fois accra - cette page web
moi j'aurais dit il à séduire pc
je n'aurai pas versé première invitée de
la fête la salsa en version française
on connaît pas pays brigands avec 36
musiciens cubains est une vraie passion
pour cette musique métisse pour un
gâteau
on vous écoute un air de salsa ya les
percussions qui viennent d'afrique il ya
les cuisines des grands orchestres de
viol il ya les mélodies qui viennent
d'europe
les mélodies sont souvent hispanisante
très européenne italienne en fait et
même je me suis laissé dire que par
exemple le cha-cha-cha l'original ça
c'est une danse française et la
contredanse qui est apportée par les
boucaniers huitième ciel pour la version
originale
il suffisait de suivre l'appel fernanda
abreu cette brésilienne mélange funk
samba s'est repris et les pamphlets et
lorsqu'elles arrivent sur ces leviers de
fer blanc ce n'est pas seulement pour le
plaisir des yeux
ses poils en fer blanc c'est un symbole
pour moi cela montre que l'on peut
transformer la pauvreté en une source de
richesse culturelle et pour ceux qui ont
préféré faire les loire au lieu de venir
dans le cher bonne nouvelle fernanda
bréhu sera bientôt en concert à paris
mort à l'âge de 59 ans de roland topor
dessinateur réalisateur peintre
humoriste scénariste comédien un
provocateur né je panique dont je me
marre était sa seule devise
imaginez un pays dans tous les livres
des plus courants au plus précieux ray
disparu plus un seul témoignage du passé
c'est ce qui est arrivé au cambodge
soumis à la terreur du pouvoir des
khmers rouges de 1975 à 1979
mais aujourd'hui 18 ans après cette
terrible période qui se traduit
également par un génocide de plusieurs
millions de personnes
la découverte par un spécialiste
français de l'école d'extrême orient de
la seule bibliothèque qui étaient
épargnées par ce véritable massacre
culturel notre enquête de ce soir me
n'est pas geneviève moll et claude
barnier est intitulé tant qu'il y aura
des vivres
il faut partir la lumière rasante du
petit matin est remonté le mégot en
bateau pendant deux heures pour arriver
avant la canicule un push mail c'est un
tout petit village avec une toute petite
bague ode à 200 km au nord de depuis
cinq mois ce piège apprend à déchiffrer
à clé c'est un trésor
les manuscrits d'il y a trois siècles
gravé en mer anciens sur des feuilles de
latanier il y 1 6340 yacé c'est un
miracle dans un pays où toute la culture
écrite a été effacé pendant quatre ans
entre 1975 et 1979
les khmers rouges ont assassiné tous les
intellectuels puis tous ceux qui osaient
résister au nouvel ordre le pôle pote
génocide de deux millions de personnes
les villes comme don peines ont été
vidés de leurs habitants
les campagnes se sont peuplés d'êtres
famélique soumis aux pires tortures des
centaines de milliers d'enfants ont
disparu ensuite dix ans d'occupation
vietnamienne de quoi décérébrés rappaz
pl lui faire oublier son identité
le mutiler de sa culture les muscles et
du cambodge ont été effroyablement
détruits sur le nombre de monastères que
nous avons visités sur 680 monastère que
nous avons visités 83% ont tout perdu
mais dans ceux auxquels nos lesquels il
reste encore quelque chose il risque d
des fragments des misères s'adonnent à
ce au monastère de pompeï eu un intérêt
absolument extraordinaire dans la mesure
où sur 680 monastères visités il y en a
trois mille au cambodge
c'est le seul où semble-t-il la
bibliothèque n'est pas été détruites
olivier qui est le seul français à lire
le maire ancien recherche depuis sept
ans les manifs perdu
à la fin de l'année dernière on lui
parle de cette fac god et de cette
bibliothèque qui contient à la fois des
textes liturgiques et ce qui est
beaucoup plus rare de la littérature les
grands textes narratifs cambodia la
bibliothèque a été sauvé par sa cause
dont ce vieil homme âgé aujourd'hui de
81 ans alors que les khmers rouges
avaient déjà investi le village était de
nuit nous avons mis les manuscrits dans
des chars à boeufs c'était quand du
temps de polpot justement que la pagode
ne soit détruite par les khmers rouges
et le vieil homme a dissimulé les menus
ci dans ce grenier ensuite dans les
années 80 il les a rendus à la pagode
mais dans un désordre indescriptible
lorsqu'il les a découverts à la fin de
l'année dernière olivier a formé ce type
est anne qui les ont remplacés
bien sûr avant de reconstituer les
liasses il faut les remettre en état
beckham a nice c'est complet olivier le
saisies sur l'ordinateur
il recrée ainsi petit à petit la mémoire
du cambodge
malgré les difficultés d'accès à ces
textes il ya plusieurs difficultés
ah bon il ya la forme des lettres qui
n'est pas familière aux jeunes et
ensuite il y à une fête que
l'orthographe n'est pas fixé
c'est-à-dire qu'il ya des variantes
orthographiques le même on peut se faire
de plusieurs façons sur le même
feuillets ce qui complique évidemment la
lecture grâce à ce travail qui n'aurait
pas pu avoir lieu sans l'école française
d'extrême orient
les jeunes bourse de buddh ce mail
peuvent retourner aux sources d'énergie
bouddhistes dans quelques instants la
météo sophie davant 20h50 votre série
l'instit suivi de ça se discute avec
jean luc delarue dernier journal aux
alentours de minuit florence dauchez
demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités gérard
leclerc recevra le vice-président du df
pierre méhaignerie trésor philippe
lefait quant à moi je vous retrouverai à
20 heures je souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne bonsoir